but whether or not someone's going to  cheat on their partner has nothing to do  with the amount of money with their  characters so but okay if if someone I  just think men are men and it's easy to  say like let's take Tiger Woods it's  easy to say like why you know why did  Tiger Woods cheat but most men don't  have a bus full of models waiting for  them and I think most men even even good  great men with character if they are in  a position where women are are standing  at the Finish Line begging to have sex  with them they might do it and that's  where a lot of the the top two percent  of men might be this is what I always  say if you dated NBA player basketball  player I don't I don't really feel bad  you get cheated on like I I don't I